Die chinesische weltraumbehörde hat die kontrolle über ihr welt, raumlabor tiangong 1 verloren die raumstation bewegt sich seitdem
Unkontrolliert auf die erde zu jetzt gibt es aktuelle berechnungen und vorhersagen zum zeitpunkt, des absturzes
Und es sieht nicht gut aus zwar wird ein großteil von
ssangyong 1 schon sehr bald in der atmosphäre verglühen doch bis zu
100 kilogramm schwere brocken könnten auf der erde einschlagen wo und wann wie ist die lage jetzt in klicks zum tanzen fiction
herzlich willkommen
Es ist nicht das erste mal dass wir uns um
weltraumschrott gedanken machen müssen weil er auf
kollisionskurs mit der erde ist vielleicht erinnert sich der eine oder andere noch was hat 91 vielen bruchstücke des sowjetischen raumstation
silent 7 auf argentinien herab menschen wurden zum glück nicht verletzt
weltraumexperten un experten fordern immer wieder dass ausgediente stationen und satelliten direkt
Im weltraum recycelt werden anstatt sie wieder mehr oder minder
unkontrolliert auf die erde stürzen zu lassen und ja für django 1 gehen dass auf jeden fall nicht
Im september 2011 hat china tiangong-1 ins all geschickt übersetzt heißt das übrigens
Also diese chinesische nicht dauerhaft bemannte raumstation, so viel wie himmlischer palast und tatsächlich ist eine art palast für den
weltraum zumindest 8,5 tonnen schwer etwa
So groß wie ein linienbus und ausgestattet
Mit einem 14 kubikmeter großen labor sowie einer kleinen wohn ecke für die besucher von jcom1 in den letzten sechs jahren hat das raumlabor
mehrere kopplungsmanöver mit
chinesischen raumschiffen der schein zu reihe hinter sich gebracht doch schon
Im letzten jahr war zwang 1 wohl außer kontrolle geratenen raumfahrt experten und expertinnen macht dem vergangenen herbst die angabe dass
china das labor schon seit märz
2016 nicht mehr steuern kann die folge rang eins bewegt sich seitdem
unkontrolliert auf die erde zu der zeit kreis die station nach chinesischen berechnungen wohl in einer mittleren höhe von etwa 3 111
Kilometern im mai waren es noch rund 350 kilometer
Regelmäßig gibt es dazu status updates aus china jetzt gibt es aktuelle berechnungen wonach teile der chinesischen
Raumstation schon bald auf die erde stürzen werden dies wird wohl ende 2017 der fall sein spätestens aber im april
2018 einen ähnlichen zeitraum hat übrigens auch die amerikanische organisation
aero space berechnet demnach wird shandong 1 irgendwann zwischen ende dezember
2017 ende februar 2018 abstürzen also alles wird schon bald passieren
Dann soll shandong 1 in die dichter werdende atmosphäre eintreten die teile die nicht komplett verbrennen
Also alles was nicht verglühte beim eintritt die werden dann auf die erde treffen und dazu hat jetzt der renommierte astrophysiker jonathan mcdowell
Von der harvard university, im britischen guardian geäußert er schließt nicht
Aus dass wrackteile mit einem gewicht von bis zu 100 kilogramm auf die erde stürzen können das ist nicht lustig denn
Im gegensatz zu einem asteroiden ist der einschlag auf die erde
unausweichlich doch das risiko dass menschen getroffen werden könnten das ist nach angaben verschiedener
raumfahrt experten und expertinnen eher klein das wurde gerade in toulouse verkündet wo sich in diesem monat mehr als
100 astronauten astronauten zum 30
weltkongress der
astronauten getroffen hatten doch schäden am boden können genauso wenig wie auswirkungen auf den flugverkehr
eben nicht
zu 100 prozent ausgeschlossen werden noch ist es also kaum vorhersehbar was genau passieren wird und wo welche
trümmerteile landen könnten das alles wird sich wohl erst kurz vorher
abschätzen lassen wenn überhaupt china hat jetzt angekündigt kurz vor dem absturz eine vorhersage für den absturz ort zu machen
Wenn ihr nicht verpassen wollt
wo das sein wollt und auch videos
Zu allen anderen themen nicht verpassen sollte man hier ein abo aufs auge und vergesst nicht den
Genau auf die glocke damit ihr auch von den neuen videos erfahrt hier geht es weiter mit
Weltraumschrott bedroht die erde mit noch mehr infos zum thema sehr sehr spannend und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt ein